what the hell is a second brain and why
does it help you organize your Digital
Life and unlock your creative potential
think of things you already do you might
have a journal imagine if everything you
wrote in that journal or diary was saved
forever was searchable that you could
actually drive insights from it you
could go ask it a question what have I
thought about money in the past what
have I thought about personal growth how
have my dates been in the past what did
I learn you could actually mine the
insights from that notes you took from
books or articles grocery lists packing
lists travel itineraries bookmarks that
you saved from the web any kind of
document that you've created from the
past all these things are things we
largely already do to some capacity but
now imagine getting all of that material
all of that stuff is just information
and you centralize it all in one single
central place where you know will be
preserved forever you can always search
for things what would be the value of
the the aggregated sum of all that
material that's your second brain